you because your partner is a reflection
of you who you choose is a reflection of
you
then that does play a part in him
thinking okay is this somebody who i
want to represent me to the world does
that make sense so
i think you know
like chris you said you've got a name
right yeah right and you're nigerian in
it yeah so i'm nigerian so respect in
our culture is huge
massive and there are a lot of other
cultures like asian cultures
like there are a lot of other cultures
where respect is very important so
yeah i think um
i think that's when you say about being
a man part of being a man
is having the level of respect that you
desire which is you know a lot of guys
may look at will smith and be like he
doesn't have a lot of respect right now
do you know what i mean and he hasn't
for a long time i think i think that's a
collective thing i think everybody wants
to be respected and i completely and
again another conversation that we've
had
like societies that are much more
collective they're way less
individualistic
uk especially american society very
individualistic whereas if you're taking
countries asia africa there is a lot
more uh
importance on what society is a home and
how you fit into society as a whole yeah
the community and i think that's a
really good thing in some senses but
those countries also have some of the
highest rates of suicide because they
have so much social shame
sorry i'm i think
i just have the highest
yeah but
i would say actually have the lowest
rates which is confused a lot of social
scientists yeah they have less look at
like japan it has one of the highest
rates because of social stigma and shame
if they do something wrong
when i went to japan like my my
understanding was it was more like
one um
it's a very individualistic society like
so yeah like people are dying alone in
their apartment there
oh yeah
and and men are working themselves to
death so i don't i don't think it's like
social stigma but i don't i'm not saying
in terms of
people i'm not talking about people's
isolation because japan also has a
problem with not enough people having
children yeah i know because it's back
to like the individualistic like like
japan has a problem with like women like
that like getting old and not being able
to find husbands basically right now but
but historically and it's still the case
that they have very clear social rules
like even in terms of things if you
would never hold hands with your partner
or keep your partner on the street
because
society that's like that's frowned upon
socially really because i i went there
when i was younger and like that the
couple i stayed with like they were i
don't know that was not the case for
whatever
it's the same it's like that in uae
they're very strict about like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah so and i'm saying more
that the thing with
with with guys and this thing of okay i
want to be respected by my men and i
completely see that and i completely see
that and especially in other countries
where that is even more important or
different cultures where that's really
important and what being a man is
differently defined i think that's why
it's important to shift the societal
narrative of what we define as being a
good man as what we because i think it's
a lot of pressure to put on that i do
but i just think i just think things
just like are
like i'm never gonna cause when we're
saying we need to change society that's
just like you putting your world view on
to society and saying this is how you
should think
i don't do what i'm saying like like
because we have intern like like this is
what i mean when i say we feel shame
like that's that's a natural instinct
and there's a reason like everyone feels
the same like there's a reason men
respect the president of the united
states and look at that as a successful
man like there's a reason like women are
attracted to power ambition like some
stuff i don't think we can just
tell ourselves not to do it just like is
and i think for sure there's a certain
element of we
you know you can't always make someone
think the same way as you i can't
magically force the uae to be
progressive overnight i can't make them
respect women i can't change like i as
an individual can't help these things
and i completely understand that for
some societies some cultures they don't
want that they don't want me to come in
and be like well i think but without
things like that we'd still have fgm
being acceptable every year a female
child
which is is really widespread especially
in africa like and the more that we talk
about that and say actually that's
really not acceptable and i know a lot
of people make the argument the fallacy
of tradition we talk about in philosophy
the fallacy of tradition it's like just
because it's a traditional thing doesn't
mean it's a good thing or the right
thing or it benefits people so i think
there's it's i think i think it's a
give-and-take thing i think it's a thing
of no you shouldn't force your world
view and you shouldn't force your
opinion and people are entitled to their
opinion but i think sometimes it's like
these things actually aid people so i
would never want a man to think you know
he has to act this way because without
the respect of someone else and he cares
really what this guy thinks then he's
less of a man and if he's less of a man
then who is he like
do you think that's just like even when
you say like i don't want to say less of
a man because it's like
i just feel like that's like dishonest
like there's hierarchies in every just
like every society of life and you can't
say like pretend they don't exist
doesn't make them not exist so for
example like a victoria's secret model
is hotter than me and if you're gonna
like come up to me and say like oh
you're just as hot like
you could say that
like
but that's that's life and it's the same
thing with like guys there's hierarchies
with like men in terms of like and
because a lot of it's like they men
value like other men like they pick it
like they they pick who they respect and
who they don't
like yeah i mean yeah there's there's
hierarchy in in everything whether
that's attractiveness or your kind of
social standing and you see it i was
saying before you see it so much in
schools in terms of popular kind of
popularity groups and i think it becomes
more redundant when you're in kind of
day-to-day society but i think the
problem with this this thing of what
what makes a good man or what i mean
what makes a good woman
it's not only are they kind of two
different things but i think that
they're abstract and i think in the same
way we go what is our net what is what
is a great british value well i think
it's supply and demand it's like supply
like when we go to talk about a good man
and a good woman it's supply and demand
it's like who do the most men want who
do the most women want
you know
i just think goodness is is tied much
more to
who you are as a person and less about
okay what do other people think of you
and actually do you treat people nicely
i think that's right like a good man is
the same thing as what a good woman is
right but usually like i don't know
i don't think debate what what a good
man yes i think i think the original
point was just that he was i think when
he was saying more of a man
i think is what we would
call a good example of what a man could
be and is
part of that or what contributes to that
is him having a respectable partner or
a perceived respectable partner because
i keep using this because it's fresh but
like will smith he's a good man
but i don't think he's been respected
for a long time
and yeah he's not been respected as a
man for a long especially within his
relationship but he's a very good man i
just i just don't think putting
limitations especially on the situation
of like and this is this isn't an attack
on you at all of what you said it's more
just like the phrasing of it makes me go
like
because i think um not me you can say it
and not me
it doesn't i encourage you it's like be
a man no it doesn't make me think don't
say it it's more that i think um
i think they're putting putting a
limitation on your partner in order to
make you seem more respectable is not
necessarily healthy well women do that
to men though
that doesn't make it healthy
no i i feel like
it um
the quality of the woman or like for
example if she has an audience just for
like for example it does affect you as a
man for example
look at will smith right before before
we knew all this stuff we knew about
jada right we thought will smith was
like top dude he was the man fresh
fresh prince on the show